est ce que tout ceci n'est pas dérisoire
j'ai créé un monstre
maintenant je dois vivre avec
[Musique]
dil bientôt sera le seul à rayonner
je ne vois pas quel point la rue est
devenue l'aide monstrueusement l'aide
tu peux te plaindre me tue à vis de la
planète mon cher et à la planète survie
de l'appuyer autrement maintenant ce
n'est pas son nom qu'il faut vendre
c'est lui je me sens très différentes
il semble en revanche
le défier approche une rien comme ça
travaille
tiens
des gens vont adorer
chaque de bascher de beaumarchais x
alors
le laisse pas nous détruire des fois je
ferme les yeux
et s'offre je ne vois que des choses
lourdes et son banc
[Musique]
jacques
j'aimerais arrêter
on y arrivera
je pense que vous êtes le seul
aujourd'hui
j'étais plus de concurrence c'est bien
moindre
[Musique]